so thrive away has three main features
the first is thrive mode it blocks all
calls texts notifications for whatever
period that you set for thrive mode so
it's really like my phone is almost off
in a sense it's it's a do not disturb
mode the second feature which is really
important is it's bi-directional so if
somebody calls or texts you in that time
they get a text that says Dana is in
thrive mode Schieffer in the next 20
minutes text her call her back then and
then the third one which is really
really really important is the dashboard
having more analytics really helps
people understand just how much time
they're spending because sending a
message out saying Dana is in thrive
mode both gives you the space to focus
on whatever you're doing without
worrying that people coming and reaching
out to you are not knowing that you're
thinking you're ignoring right we feel
like we have to respond right exact
everything then it also changes the
culture it changes that feeling that you
have to respond right away and how does
science fit into all of this is there a
science behind how much time you should
be spending on your phone where you
should be pulling back a little bit I
don't think the science is clear on the
number of hours one of the things that's
really coming into clarity is it's less
about the number of minutes and hours
and more about the quality and so one of
our recommendations is to do an audit of
your home screen look at the to look at
the apps on your home screen are they
serving you are they things you want to
click unconsciously are they trying to
suck your attention and and eat up more
of your time for instance I've moved
Facebook from my home screen I almost
never look for it it's too easy when
it's on that home screen and you know
your brain is conditioned to just find
it right right it's and that's the
problem when it gets messed up when your
apps move around on your phone suddenly
you don't know where you're so it's good
- it's good to trick your brain and to
force you to make conscious decisions
over the apps that you're looking to use
as opposed to these unconscious
decisions that your fingers just do for
you without thinking so bring a
consciousness to how we're using these
devices bringing a consciousness being
more intentional about the way you're
using the devices listen if you if being
on the phone connecting with a friend or
a loved one or a colleague is fueling
your humanity go for it if being on
Facebook for 10 minutes a day makes you
feel great
go for it if being on Facebook for 50
minutes a day doesn't make you feel
great maybe figure out a way to stop at
10
you